[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this week's edition of
bone-in of the week mm-hmm gabe we had a
great poll we had a great poll there was
three great contestants on it
i could say it might be one of our best
polls yet
best pull ever it's fabulous yeah
tripping
the best many people many people
are saying
it was the best goal ever we had three
great candidates now we've been waiting
for a long time we've talked about doing
this for a long time where we just put
one person on the pole it never seemed
appropriate until this week um but our
three contestants this week were donald
trump the cheeto dust mobster and
grandpa poopy pants himself so
these three candidates deserve great
accolades for being on this poll for
bonehead of the week
so where where where shall we start with
these three contestants for bonehead of
the week
it really is it was all week and and
let's go
let's not let's not get away from the
elephant in the room donald trump
absolutely [ __ ] himself in every way
every which fashion dude there was
ketchup all over the walls it looked
like a [ __ ] jackson pollock at
mar-a-lago guaranteed well let's catch
up on this week's bone end of the week
so where are we going to start first
because i think we should start with uh
this search warrant or the raid as as
some people are calling it some people
are scared to call it a raid i'm not
really scared to call it a raid i think
search warrant raid whatever you want to
call it i believe that the look and the
the feel of this is not going to change
in the american you know the american
political body and how they're
discussing this um i i've even i even my
16 year old son actually mentioned that
he saw on one of his social media sites
that he's on that there was a video of
donald trump talking about how the mob
pleads the fifth and then he plead the
fifth he's like that's crazy which it
he's like politics never leaks into my
thread and it leaked into my thread yeah
so people are paying attention to this
people are paying attention this week
and we'll get to the fifth thing here
soon yeah yeah but the first part of the
week the really the search warrant and
the raid but more than that because we
talked about this before and i've said
this the rate is important
the search warrant the issuing of the
search warrant and the execution was
important but more importantly
more importantly i believe that the
uh the thing that was most that was
that was the hilarious part of it is the
right wing reacting to this in real time
it was [ __ ] fantastic tucker carlson
even hasn't even been on a show all week
he was i guess he's still changing his
diapers
you know some might ask you know where
in the world is tucker carlson uh
because it seems a little suspect that
all of a sudden when this raid happens
not saying that they're connected but
when you know mar-a-lago gets searched
by the fbi
tucker carlson is
not in you have that video of tucker
carlson that night um during the raid
where um tucker carlson
light
comes on our wish.com tucker carlson
comes on air that would be a great clip
to show here because um that that just
shows in that moment the absolute freak
out of
of uh fox news and the late night fox
news the prime times host
tucker carlson and the like let me uh
let me if you've got that yeah i'll
search for the video but they absolutely
freaked out they were all freaking out
even marjorie taylor green was freaking
out um
of course trump on on fraud social has
been freaking out oh yeah
he has been uh [ __ ] himself
100 percent
right all week it's in and really that
stems from this raid but we also see
this week with this bonehead um the
fifth amendment which we're going to
we're really going to get to here did
you find
well let me play this clip while you're
waiting because um i think this is
hilarious um this is a reaction from a
trump supporter we played it earlier in
the week but boy it really does um
feels like this was ages ago that we
watched this person with this really
huge foam hat and talk about how it's an
injustice that a criminal would be would
be raided by the fbi after committing
crimes let's watch an administration the
democrats are weaponizing the fbi and it
has to stop
the fbi is not here to weaponize against
another president it never has happened
before
um they should go after things that are
clearly a violation meaning the hunter
laptop which they don't even have to
investigate because the laptop is
all of that is not investigated
president trump is investigated because
to say that he's running
and he will win again
so here you have the trump supporter
outside with a really weird ass hat
apparently these hats are available
online if you'd like to get one a
dumbass hat from the conservative comedy
store
yeah well comedy
okay so it is hilarious though that
these hats are real
that's a funny thing now here's the
thing about this clip and about what
she's talking about because what they're
saying what the trump supporters the
mogalodites the internet trolls the
[ __ ] gr the people being grifted by
the grifter-in-chief what they're saying
is oh my god i can't believe joe biden
is politicizing and weaponizing the doj
and the fbi like donald trump said he
would right literally that is whether we
should have done that lock her up and
get rid of that we need to lock hunter
biden and joe biden in jail like they're
calling for all these people to be sent
down to gitmo and hanged
out
they will talk they will project their
own because this is the worry right the
worry is that
the worst thing possible is true right
these claims of classified documents
nuclear codes nuclear nuclear codes
sorry
were
were at trump's fingertips right and
mar-a-lago is not that safe
when somebody uh earlier this year was
able to steal
devices she was sentenced to eight uh
eight months in prison i think seven
months in prison but
it's not secure it there are definitely
holes in security and where people can
access and it's a place where if you're
a president you would not
think to
you know if you were of sound mind and
body which trump is clearly not uh you
would you would think yeah yeah you know
what these aren't my documents and i
definitely shouldn't keep it here at a
residence slash a public or private club
where people can come in and out right
and i have events at weddings this and
that i have to jump
he split a special lock where it was
come on and you know what you know what
made me think of and i said this earlier
what it made me think of trump buying a
special lock you know the little the
kids diaries and it has the little hard
lock rocket yeah a little heart lock it
on that that's what i envisioned like he
put that was the lock that he used is
some kind of like
trinket locket
like i wouldn't i wouldn't be surprised
if that was the thing like he's like hey
you wanted to my safe and it was a piggy
bank or something like you know
something so childish you know where he
was like they broke into my safe well
here's wish.com tucker carlson that
evening um as the moguladites were
descending on uh palm beach island there
in florida his his daughter-in-law goes
on uh tucker carlson's white privilege
tonight but tucker wasn't there it was
wish.com tucker it was tucker with the
facelift um he asked
laura why why would they raid this place
laura uh you've spoken to your
father-in-law um therefore you have the
most immediate information of anybody
we've spoken with tonight
do does he know do you he definitely
would not lie to you yeah
like what are you talking about what the
hell are you talking about of course he
would lie to her i mean over and over
and over again but let's listen i do
know why his home was rated
he believes it's the documents in
question that uh you know everybody's
been really upset about from the white
house look my father-in-law as anybody
knows who's been around him a lot loves
to say things like newspaper clippings
magazine clippings photographs documents
that he had every authority will to take
from the white house which you don't
need that's not true if there was ever a
wrong answer that is it that's all
[ __ ] we talked about this yesterday
because there's this there he keeps
bringing up a guy named hugh sane who's
taking d presidential documents to
chicago and he fails to mention that in
chicago where those documents are going
is a [ __ ] presidential library who is
being operated under the authority of
national archives and the national
archives are the ones taking those
documents there now
when you leave the white house there is
from what i understand there is a
certain procedure
that you go through if you want to take
property of the government with you and
you can have custody of it it doesn't
mean it's yours
it is still the property of the
government it is still part of the
presidential archive but they will give
you a pro there's a protocol to get
permission for those pieces of the
archive to leave and be in your custody
for the time being they do the same
thing gabe when they want a piece of the
presidential archive to be moved
somewhere else into the custody of
someone else if there is a procedure for
the custody and it is done that way and
we talked about it yeah well we've been
talking about it all week that this idea
that that
that donald trump is going to get a
presidential library frankly is
ridiculous unless it's a coloring book
factory but the thing is is the national
archive is a [ __ ] federal building
ran by the federal government us it has
given funding by us the federal
government to house those documents
that's the whole point is to make sure
that we the people we the government
have an archive of our office the office
of the presidency when whoever's name is
on the building was holding that office
it really is not that complicated and i
actually think that donald trump
um not only has is probably going to be
charged with crimes here with whatever
whatever the crime is that they're going
to find that he committed with these
documents um but also it's really going
to hurt his chances of ever receiving an
actual presidential library somewhere
they will probably hold his office's uh
records in the actual
our archives in washington dc there were
i hope i i really hope there's never a
[ __ ] building that's printed by his
name i mean i would his name in library
right i mean
like if you were to give that guy with
we know you having or using the
precedent that is set right now which is
this guy took documents and even after
he said we gave all the documents if we
had him we'd give him to the government
turns out he was lying and had almost
double the amount of documents whether
the copies or additional uh
documents
he was still holding on to and that's
why the fbi came to search his home
now
which again was signed off by
christopher wray the fbi director
republican that he appointed right that
he put in that position
also
uh
you've got
the the judge right which is uh bruce
reinhardt he's a republican judge down
in florida right and then you've got uh
merrick garland like all of these people
were attached to it and they they said
yep we should do it okay cool i'll sign
out from the fbi and then you've got a
judge down in florida who said
well i mean everything seems to check
out here this is a reasonable concern
that a president is still holding on to
classified documents because they also
they they are privy to whatever the
search warrant was the thing that trump
said release you know i'll release the
search warrant which you know you and i
both don't believe he will
but
that's the thing these people have seen
it and go yeah the evidence looks pretty
[ __ ] damning like i can't i can't not
sign it right i have to sign this
because if i do
then it would show that it is i am
deciding a political side and that's you
know keep in mind that all the people
that were in play here were either
people appointed by president trump or
republicans or it's coming all the way
up from the top which is you know
merrick garland saying yeah we should
look into this right for all the people
that were like why isn't you know
merrick garland doing something quick
enough why go after trump it's like
turns out
there was some pretty big [ __ ] going on
and it wasn't like the idea that we
thought january 6 was the craziest thing
and then we find out and we had joked
for years during his presidency for his
first term because he's a one-term
president
that he had his finger on the nuclear
codes right on the nuclear button at any
point he was going to nuke that
hurricane down in florida
he was going to send he's going to send
missiles into mexico all right exactly
and so you look at this and you're like
oh man we were kind of joking like the
guy was is not totally stable right he's
not the stable genius that everyone says
he is
and so well he's the only one that says
that right you know i'm the stable
genius or whatever yeah man woman person
camera tv right like that's the guy
who's like i can remember these words
like great uh for you
but
but you've got this guy that you're like
yeah he is a
someone to be concerned about right so
the idea that he would actually get a
library to hold on to documents that are
classified or that are secure
he would definitely try to you know he's
like
the back door in here but that's the
thing is a lot of people
that's the that's the argument here is
that he's not went to the proper
protocol for those documents that were
in the 15 boxes and the 12 boxes uh you
know following
and he he probably did not follow the
protocol for any of that stuff and the
reason why is because he wouldn't
obtained it and took it with him if he
had to follow that protocol now
in a presidential library it's not like
the president can just walk in and take
whatever he wants
that's not how it works that is a
federal building with their name on it
we fund it the national archive runs it
and that's why this nonsense about obama
and all this [ __ ] is just ridiculous
right but uh speaking of ridiculous
here's jesse water and dan bongino's
almost immediate reaction and this is
one of the best reasons this is not a
laughing matter tony right it's not
funny damn it uh it's hilarious actually
yeah but and and danbon gino points out
how hilarious it is let's listen
i just want to say in closing
listen america they're laughing at you
the left thinks this is hilarious if you
doubt me just go to any of their
platforms twitter elsewhere right now
they think this we're laughing at
ourselves hilarious
you know what
so gabe and i i think i can find it here
probably
but there was also a video speaking of
laughing huh and they think it's funny
there was actually a [ __ ] airplane
that they paid oh yeah to go over to go
over the uh to go over mar-a-lago and
fly and i think we should just everyone
should donate to have this plane just
constantly you know as long as it's
light outside have this [ __ ] plane be
flying over mar-a-lago
it was a big banner said
for for the people out there who say is
this the one guy that you sent
no no no no i'm gonna i'm gonna send you
the one right now that is yeah i got i
got it right here i got it okay okay
cool um so here is here's the um here's
the
the the video of the plane
cut the sound here but you see you see
it says hahahahaha the banner just it
just says ha ha ha ha ha because they
are like we are laughing at you we are
laughing at you because we and and the
thing is
we told you boneheads this we told you
this that this was not going to go in
your favor
not just making him the president not
just making him the lead of the party
but continuing this nonsense after what
happened on january 6 and after he left
the office of the presidency we told you
this stupid [ __ ] was going to happen
yeah let's go to a video that you have
here
um of lindsey graham and then i want to
get to the fifth amendment stuff because
i know you made a video on the fifth
amendment thing so i want to get to that
real quick um because that was also
another boneheaded thing this week but
this is again jesse waters interviewing
lindsey graham i gotta say jesse waters
there was a there was a part in my brain
i was like does jessie waters get on the
list this week because if there was any
like any trump stan
that this week that was using his
platform or their platform for
uh to push disinformation about what the
search warrant was for what this oh it
was jessie for sure it was just because
it wasn't just on this show it's on the
five because in the on the five two
yeah yeah well that's all yeah that's
yeah is it all the same or is it uh let
me well there's also the five clip that
i'm thinking of right now and let me let
me go okay let me play this one i'm
having you on lindsay you know you and i
have debated about things and i've seen
you pretty spitting mad over ukraine
but you you don't seem as mad as you
were about this then you've been mad
about ukraine i don't understand why
people aren't lighting their hair on
fire i don't understand why people
aren't out in the streets because he
committed crimes let's just see what's
in the war
jesse jesse waters like get out in the
streets and start committing violence
damn it why aren't you doing that yet
and they've been doing this this is the
third election
this is the third election we know they
doctor evidence we know they plant
evidence
we know they hide evidence we know they
lie we know they leak
there's lindsey graham saying that the
fbi plants evidence
a sitting united states senator
who claims to bla back the blue and he's
claiming that the fbi is planning
evidence get the [ __ ] out of here man
these people sunk to a whole new low
they won't stop um it's just ridiculous
i want to go to uh who the uh because we
got we got an alpha cuck and we've got a
dishonorable mention this year too you
know we do the alpha cuck and
dishonorable mention so gabe who is the
alpha cuck this week let's find out
wow well
i don't even know i told him i told my
interns to find the worst person to be
whoever got cocked the worst yeah um put
them on why did he get i think he got
cucked for this fifth amendment thing
that's is that why you put him on the
couch yeah yeah yeah he totally got cut
100
was an alpha cuck this week because he
said in the past
only the mob takes the fifth why would
you take the why would you plead the
fifth if you're innocent right like all
these questions of like
uh the thing himself he cucked himself
because then we find out because tisch
james was like yeah [ __ ] this guy right
and they were like oh yeah i was there
when he was pleading the fifth
in new york this week well yes she she
was in the room and she was asking him
questions um
now
there is some um
i don't know how long it was but it was
apparent that he was gonna you know plea
the fifth the entire time like he wasn't
gonna he wasn't gonna stop doing that um
and i'm trying to find this video of
yours that you had uh put out on the on
him though
uh
on him saying yeah the mob pleads the
fifth because i like that video i
actually put it in the um the version of
my rant now here it is i've got it okay
um of the uh
the video i sent over that's on the
minus touch network's youtube channel
but here is here is uh trump loves the
fifth he loves it he loves saying it
even yeah
when you have
your staff
taking the fifth amendment yeah taking
the fifth
what's funny about this one is this is
where he's in a debate with hillary yeah
yeah so this is this is also during the
series of debates where hillary was like
if this guy becomes [ __ ] president
this is how it's going to go
right right right what you're watching
is what you will continue to watch and
like no he'll surely change and be
president yeah he won't be that bad and
then it was like everything she said it
was like yep she was
she was even warning you about the
nuclear codes the nuclear the [ __ ] the
nuclear
she is
you know i'm not saying she's like uh
a suit sayer you know or like uh someone
who can predict the future but she's
on the money this is like us predicting
stuff and you know i said doubt me it's
really not that difficult yeah i know i
know i mean like she understands the
pattern that trump has and what he does
and so it would it would totally make
sense
that he would continue to do that
especially if he's given even more power
right the guy's a [ __ ] egomaniac and
well i mean he's the king he's the king
of being predictably unpredictable right
yeah yeah that's the whole thing i think
that's that's that's trump is like that
he did was surprising
and kind of unsurprising at the same
time right right but in the end well i
mean it's shocking but it's not
surprising like it's shocking that that
would happen
he had the nuclear codes
that's that's crazy and that's shocking
but like um
i could have totally seen that coming
let's let's finish here so they're not
prosecuted i think it's disgraceful if
you're not guilty of a crime what do you
need immunity for pleading the fifth
amendment pleading the fifth amendment
taking the fifth amendment the fifth
amendment in the fifth amendment fifth
amendment fifth amendment fifth
amendment horrible
do you think do you think that's
actually how he was in like with tis
james like she would go to say something
he's like fifth amendment she yeah fifth
amendment fifth amendment fifth
amendment he was that's what he also
said it was fifth amendment but then i
think uh
i think i saw something about him not
even saying fifth amendment at one point
he just said
same answer as previous or same answer
as before
uh which is like wow you can't even say
fifth amendment you have to go like yeah
i just said that i just said which which
in his standards that's pretty that's
pretty low he can't even say the same
thing over and over again that's pretty
low which which i'm like is that legally
allowed i don't know
but it seems weird it's like which
you said you plead the fifth and then
you're like oh it you know like the same
as the previous answer which is like you
didn't actually say you plead the fifth
you just said like the other one which i
i don't know like again i'm no lawyer i
don't know how that works but the idea
that you can just be like
saying you know
i'm using the same as my previous answer
whatever seems a little longer in a
roundabout way of just saying uh the
fifth the fifth well
so um ben meizelos of legal af did a
video on the midas touch uh network
about pleading the fifth and and they
talked about it um also i believe last
night on the minus such uh podcast um he
was talking about how
like in a criminal trial when you're
you're on a criminal indictment and you
use the fifth to not self-incriminate
yourself like they can't use they can't
use that you use the fifth against you
right so right if they ask you a
question you plead the fifth the the
prosecution in that sense can't use that
against you in court right because you
are you are using that amendment to crim
incriminate not to incriminate yourself
but in a civic or a civil trial so this
is a civil trial that the state of new
york is placing on the trump
organization in a civil trial it's not
the same way because you're not you
can't incriminate yourself in a civil
trial uh yeah yeah i'm sorry i have some
breaking news related related to this to
the fifth amendment no no it's about the
olympics so we can go through the fifth
amendment but i've got breaking news
that relates to what was what was
searched for oh well let's go to that
let's go that we we rarely have breaking
news on the bonehead of the week i like
this breaking news on bone of the week
about the bonehead of the week um looks
like spiro agnews ghost is um tweeting
here breaking from wall street journal
fbi agents
who search donald trump's mar-a-lago
home monday removed 11 sets oh [ __ ] of
classified documents 11 sets of clock
classified i i take that as um maybe one
box a piece that may be where the 12
boxes is coming in yeah it's possible
yeah i'm just i'm just pointing that out
um including some marked as top secret
and meant to be only available in
special government facilities holy [ __ ]
this guy has skiff documents yeah holy
[ __ ] so this guy has these documents
that are only allowed to be in skiffs
because that's the other thing about
even like a presidential library there's
part of the presidential archive that
never actually makes it to the
presidential library because it can't be
in that room because there's not secure
enough facilities in that in that
building well also so for people who
also know like if anyone doesn't know
what a skiff is it's basically like a
secret
sensitive compartmented information what
is it
stands for um
sensitive compartmented information
facility okay
so basically you're like in an
undisclosed location
uh you know a white room essentially
where nothing is tapped in you don't
have any line out like it is it there is
no way for anyone to penetrate right
they they won't allow you to bring like
cameras in or yeah yeah yeah it's your
you it's basically what happens when
like a director like christopher nolan
says hey you can come
to
um this location
and you can read this script there's
only one copy you can read this script
no phones nothing is allowed in here you
can take as much time as you need to
read it
uh but the other idea too is that like a
skip is somewhere where it's you know
these are these are areas that you
wouldn't typically know of you know
they're
they're out and about and only the
military or national security defenses
would actually know the locations right
because if you give away a skiff then
you're like oh well you know someone
could plan an attack or something but
yeah it's basically going into an area
where nobody knows about uh because it's
for national security uh
issues right
and having a room that is completely
sealed off from anything else no
electronics no no recording
so they can actually read this material
in private as private as you can get
and so the fact that
these documents were supposed to only be
in places like that
like i don't even know how you walk out
of a place like that you know
or like how you can get your hands on
those documents well i mean because they
would be in a skiff in the white house
he probably lifted them from the skiff
in a white house this guy was known to
eat documents flush documents there's no
but i'm surprised that you wouldn't even
stuff it in this diaper even if stuffing
in his diaper and walk out i mean well
yeah i mean like i was surprised like
even if you were in a skiff room inside
the white house right or anywhere else
yeah but this guy was known to break the
rules and everyone just stand back and
go well he's the president what are we
gonna do right which brings me to my
dishonorable mention of the week gabe we
have a dishonorable mention this week
too as we do every week
oh we should we should have the sound
effect boom
uh dishonorable mention is donald trump
i believe that he's the dishonorable
mention this week i want to believe it's
because he keeps stoking now this this
underlying terrorism and um and his
allies are doing the exact same thing i
want to show you here patriot take
points out uh ali alexander he's a he's
a insurrectionist he's a treasonous
insurrectionist he was planning the
attack on our democracy
um and it points it out well here stop
the steel founder ali alexander wants
his followers to disclaim non-violence
and quotes warns were in final stages of
the coup against american people so i'm
not i think this is projection
like this is projection well yeah but
here is here is his statement on
this is telegram right yep this is
totally this is telegram um
he says this is what ally alexander says
biden approved
garland authorized rey executed right
which one of those things is not true
okay
um we're in the final stages of the coup
against the american people which that
seems that statement there seems like
projection to me
like hey folks we're almost there kind
of thing not like well we also know that
uh ali alexander has a tendency to try
to be
uh
the
center of attention right whether it's
um
you know he he he was making he was
inferring
that he was going to be the secret
witness right
um
uh for the january 6 committee because
everyone's like oh man who was it going
to be who's it going to be and then he
was posting on telegram another place to
be like oh i've been asked to like you
know you know i got to come into dc now
and so like you know he's he's hanging
out with the likes of alex jones you
know uh they were down in germany
domestic terrorists exactly they were
down in georgia you know and they
actually on camera discussed like what
they had to do in order to actually be
successful right um
well he goes on to say here in this
telegram if that's what you call it uh
b.a patrick henry and warn other
patriots and he puts in here disclaim
non-violence where and when necessary
so what he's saying is make a disclaimer
that you want
non-violence
make sure there's the disclaimer there
even though that's not what you want
that's what he's saying here that's what
he's that's what he's it's what he's
saying that's what he's saying that
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and traitor hey i
don't understand why this guy isn't
[ __ ] locked up to be quite honest
with you right i think he's dangerous as
[ __ ] but uh it just goes to show you
because um i looked here
one of uh midas touch
um one of the mizellas brothers posted
just a bit ago i think about an hour ago
speaking of domestic terrorism and
threats now brett mizella supposed to
this
dude let me see if i can find it he
posted a picture of a letter that was
sent to an old midas touch address i
guess um is what this is if i can find
it man damn where i just i just had it i
just had it damn you
let me find it um but brett posted a
letter that was sent to an old minus
touch
address here it is um and he said today
i learned
well let's see today i learned a
threatening letter was sent to minus
touch the letter was sent to a location
where we no longer live or work and
contains a violent threat to shoot up a
school holy [ __ ] we have reported this
to federal authorities and
in law enforcement um who are
investigating so here is of course they
hide the address but there is uh there's
a threat sent to mind as touch um
obviously
they don't like hearing us say what
we're saying
um and they are not gonna they're not
gonna
quit this kind of stuff this kind of
garbage um so everyone you know stay
safe out there i know i know it feels
like this won't bubble over but we
watched it bubble over in cincinnati and
i believe that's why he gets
dishonorable mention is because
they're not just him but the republican
party and his little his little
magledites right out there
inside congress and on the media the far
the far right media are doing everything
they can to try to stoke violence as we
as we saw in cincinnati um yesterday
you know there was there was someone
else on my list that i was potentially
considering this week
uh for for dishonorable mention
no for the alpha [ __ ] oh okay who is
that don winslow
uh oh
oh yes you're talking about you're
talking about the guy who who if you
listen which we didn't listen to a lot
of the tape but if you go back and
listen to the domestic terrorist press
conference this morning in the house um
where those domestic terrorists were
trying to justify someone stealing
documents and blaming merrick garland
and merrick gardens the enemy the fbi
the doj's enemy it's all their fault
they're to blame and they need to be
arrested they need to be investigated
they are using the same language that
don winslow was using
um for a law and has been using for a
long time and i'm not scared to go after
him everyone said that i was going after
the left i'm not going after the left
i'm going after someone who's got a very
big a very big account a very big a very
big megaphone and they're saying they're
kicking democracy when they're down
because when i posted something against
him on the podcast account i'm because
he's blocked me on my personal and i can
show it here and i mean i the other
thing too is like he yesterday he had a
tweet that was like the last year and a
half right they've been they've been
sitting with the knowledge that he had
this like one
we don't know right they knew that he
had these things for a year and a half
right they might have had an idea and
they were going through other people
they might have been investigating and
trying to be like where did the
documents go who had clearance who had
access going through those people to be
like
don't have it don't have it don't have
it don't have it
all right well the last one on the list
is donald trump right like also keep in
mind
that for the last year and a half don
winslow like i think that he has a a big
platform and you know he he is able to
help
fund
smart yeah he
can be an effective tool for the left
100
he has the money and the resources and
he has said he was retiring from writing
and he was going to help fund other
people create videos and other content
for the left you just grip i don't know
what's what's in the process or what's
working but if that actually is actually
happening i think that could be very
effective to have him be the powerful
like bulldozing force to go through
and shine light on these other smaller
creators up and coming people
to to bring awareness around these
illegal acts that are happening so he
for the last year and half he's like
garland has to do his job why isn't he
acting why isn't he acting he's got to
go act quicker right you've got all
these memes of uh
of chris farley on the snl schedule man
living down by the motivational speaker
like down by the river and it's a meme
that says merrick garland you know like
do your job
and for he for the last year and a half
he's just been complaining about this
and then as soon as the doj merrick
garland come forward and say hey look so
yeah like we noticed that everyone has
been saying do our job and we have been
because during that time
we were investigating
him and all of the parties like this
isn't just again this is something he's
like rush and jump over and be like hey
let me get those documents back or you
know like again they had to investigate
and figure out who had them and at the
time to make sure they had the evidence
to prove
that they could get a search warrant
they could go into his home and they
could you know legally go about
searching it and not make it seem like
it was a political
act against trump it's just a criminal
act against trump because he is a serial
criminal
well again again and i pointed this out
i said did merrick garland steal your
lunch money a long time ago or some [ __ ]
you're a coward and a grifter and i hope
you're following sees you who for who
you really are now um he blocked me so
you couldn't see us but i took a
screenshot um
because he didn't block me from the pod
account which he probably will or has
already so i took a screenshot from
there it says so the fb here's it was
his quote so the fbi doj let quote
nuclear documents sit at donald trump's
home for a year and a half and people
are praising them instead of asking how
could you possibly let top secret
documents be at trump's home for a year
and a half that's the whole point why
they went there don dummy and the story
is why did doj fbi take so long this is
so stupid he absolutely has dug his
heels in so much of his this narrative
that the doj and the and merrick garland
and the united states government is not
going to prosecute trump that he cannot
see the forest through the trees and don
i implore you see the force through
these trees stop writing this [ __ ] stop
posting this [ __ ] stop grifting your
followers to think that something
nefarious is going on at the department
of justice it's not the department of
justice it's not the fbi it's not
merrick garland donald trump is the
criminal he's the one that's going to be
held accountable for this we are seeing
it live and in person not just in the
doj and the department of justice are
the merrick gardens office and the fbi
we're seeing in in the select committee
so stop with the nonsense stop with the
[ __ ] and anyone following this guy
if you like him fine
like you said i think don can be an
effective tool but he's not being he's
kicking he's kicking democracy while
it's down and someone even we've invited
him on the show we love him on the show
i'll talk to him about it i'll let him
explain himself
probably not to his
great desire of how i would do it but i
would let him explain himself but here's
the thing here's what i want to say
about this because someone said that
they had doubts themselves and i said
there's nothing wrong with doubt doubt
is different than kicking democracy
while they're down right this is well
past don winslow's doubt and his
possibility to doubt right so doubt me
doubt me
you know we're gonna make some t-shirts
i guess um let's go let's go to the
winner of the bone of the week gabe who
is the winner in our contestants here we
had some great contestants wow the
winner is donald trump you know what i
did not see that happening
couldn't even guess that couldn't even
guess that well i think i think um we
should just give the winner his due here
because everyone knows exactly he's a
traitor
he's a spy he sells our secrets i just
want to say that this is the first time
we've had one person just sweep in all
categories i know all of them and
it is it is very it is very fitting that
it was him let's give let's give the
winner a bone end of the week his due
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
never in the history of bone ended a
week have we had one person get 100 of
the vote but we we did it this week one
person got a hundred percent of the vote
and it's very fitting that that one
person i we've rigged it we [ __ ]
rigged it let's just say it we rigged it
and again we've been wanting to rig one
for a while because everyone's like why
don't you put in all the above we're
like well that would rig it to all the
above like every time and then we
wouldn't have a winner so i wanted to
see which one would get the most answers
i was like yeah i could put one on there
and it'd be a hundred percent
but i also wanted to see what would
happen if we put
all three as an option as the same
person i just wanted to see kind of
where it would lay out i mean of course
the first one on the list is gonna be
the biggest one and it just went down
from there but i was surprised that
actual people were like yeah you know
what i'm gonna go with option two donald
trump and somebody were like i'm gonna
go with option three donald trump well
maybe they were maybe they were talking
about the donald trump that played the
fifth maybe that's what we should have
done donald trump um raided donald trump
oh yeah the fifth and then donald trump
nuclear documents maybe yeah maybe we
should have been more specific yeah yeah
yeah yeah well and then we would have
made that yeah well there's gonna be a
next time with this guy probably and
he's really the only person that could
probably manage to be all three and make
it worth its wild for them all three for
us to rig it one week because you guys
love phone in the week we love bone of
the week don't forget
to to go to twitter follow tony
michael's pod you can vote there every
single week for bone in a week and you
you also need to subscribe right here on
youtube do not forget to hit that
subscribe button so you can vote here on
youtube as well
for bonehead of the week
and it's every single friday in the
second hour and we even cut it out and
we download it on all your favorite
podcast
directories apple spotify google your
favorite ones while you're there
downloading bone end of the week on
sundays because that's when we put it
there on sundays don't forget to leave
us a great review this has been this
week's edition
of boneheaded week stick around we have
a few announcements right after the song
[Music]
[Applause]